okay so where this talk is going to be
given both by DBM are in myself and so
some motivation we've been working a lot
on gene expression and by now there is a
huge number almost 2 million expression
profiles in geo and how can we make use
of these richness similarly if you look
at cosmic database there are over a
million cancer mutation profiles and
again this begs the question of how to
use it and one way to put this in
disease context is to use the disease
ontology which is like a goal like
ontology which that contains over 6,000
disease terms at this point so we'll
talk about two projects one focuses on
expression and the other on mutations we
go come from the angle of classification
but actually the emphasis will be not on
the classification itself but on the bio
marker genes which we view as indicated
of the disease and this was done jointly
with Tom height a student in my group
and Charlie an oncologist in Shiva
hospital so the first project deals with
the expression and the motivation comes
from the observation that single study
disease by a profile area stop feeding
single study disease biomarkers are
pretty good in terms of predicting but
pretty bad in terms of reproducibility
with some usability namely if you take
two such studies typically the overlap
in the biomarker set will be near zero
or definitely not significant and also
these genes are pretty far from being
you
week and as a result the biomechanical
constant context is is quite low and
what we wish to do is to find biomarkers
that will use multiple data profiles
across many disease in order to increase
the robustness and the interpretability
and there have been some studies along
these lines in the past and will refer
to some of them as we go along so here
is the overview of the our analysis
process we start by manually annotating
a set of over 13,000 profiles from geo
and these are very diverse a hundred and
seventy data set coming from 17
microarray platforms are and we manually
assign them a disease ontology terms and
then we perform classification identify
those diseases that are well classified
and for those identified a differential
genes or the genes that are good as
biomarkers again using the disease
ontology and once we have a tender
biomarkers gene set we integrate this
with other information sources like
notation their databases drug targets
and interactions in order to view to
create disease summaries that are a
highly informative so in our data set we
covered 48 participating diseases
ontology terms as you see cancer is a
big part of this set over 5500 samples
but also some other diseases and the
problem that we have at hand is
multi-label classification in which the
same sample could have multiple labels
that are all correct and there have been
several approaches to such problem first
we can learn separately
each a single class for each disease
second we could apply a beijing
correction to this single class approach
and finally we could form a power set of
the labels and then apply a multi plus
model and the data is analyzed in a live
data set out crow holiday shin namely in
each in each of our tests we put aside a
complete collection of data sets in
order to avoid any kind of problem with
with batch effects and to make the
validation as independent as possible
one can view the data the results of the
classifier is a probability matrix where
for each sample and for each disease we
have a probability that the patient had
the disease while the true labels are
binary matrix of of the disease terms
and the way to evaluate it people have
been using either global AUC namely take
all the values in this P matrix sort
them in decreasing order and compared to
the Y matrix in order to get the OC
curve alternatively and more
conservatively one can look at one
column at a time and compute
disease-based AUC score and we've been
using both now a key problem in a null
analyzing the data like this is we want
to use many diseases together but as a
result for every particular disease we
have a small sum number of samples say
500 out of our 1,300 that for 13,000
that have that were measured for this
particular disease and in this
particular tissue and typically here
that we will have both cases and
controls
the controls are typically matching they
come from the same tissue and they are
very carefully chosen on the other hand
all those other samples come from
different tissues and different studies
and they are totally unrelated but their
size is overwhelming so we have to
separate between what we call the
positive the cases for a particular
disease the negatives which are the
controls what are taken directly from
the same studies and what we call the
background controls all the rest because
if we put together the yellow and the
green as the negatives the result will
be that we will be essentially
classifying the tissue and not
classifying the disease and the size of
the cases the controls will be a tiny
compared to other other diseases so just
to drive this point home if you do a
simple experiment where you have a 500
positive and negatives which are
identical identically distributed and
you have 10,000 background controls you
will get amazingly good curves which are
totally meaningful so the point is that
we really have to distinguish in such
context where we look at many diseases
together at these three classes and the
solution is to really work come up with
a positive versus negative score and the
positive versus background so we want
the positive to be different both from
the negatives and from the background
controls and on top of it we also have a
Q value that is computed by a study
based meta-analysis so we use all these
three scores as a way to come up with a
stricture or evaluation and if we when
we apply the set of classifiers on this
data so here are a set of six
classifiers that we applied first of all
as expected compare
against the background is much easier
than comparing against the negatives so
the scores here are uniformly higher
than here and surprisingly perhaps the
classifiers that are multi-level did not
do better than simpler classifiers and
in fact if we just look at the number of
well classified diseases which is that
identified by both rock scores above
point 7 and Q value below point 05 then
the simple svm classifier was best so we
went along with it for the rest of the
analysis so here are the 24 were
classified diseases by far the majority
is from cancer but there are also some
well classified cases in
neurodegenerative diseases and
cardiovascular now we also did an
independent validation by looking at RNA
six samples taking the classifier that
we groped on the micro RNAs and testing
them when they are any sec data and the
AUC scores were extremely high but note
that with the exception of breast cancer
there are no negatives in this sample so
these are just the positive versus the
rest of their of the cancers now if we
plot their precision recalls plot we are
doing substantially better than a pnas
paper that just provided a particular
point for comparison so the global au PR
is also greatly improved now what about
robustness as you recall we said that
robustness is a big issue and since we
have collected so much data we could
take a very large class the dope the
doorway term that was largest was cancer
and we had 46
studies on it and learn separately so
partition the data into small subsets
and come up with the biomarkers on both
sets and look at the overlap and if you
take five datasets at a time this is the
jacquard score that you get for the
overlap and it is increasing when you go
up till half the data 23 data set and of
course the p-values are all very
significant but still a jacquard of
point2 is not amazingly satisfying now
assume that this is a linear curve so if
we use for all our 46 data set we will
get near 2.3 and one would need the
hundred data sets to reach a jacquard of
point six so they the bottom line is
that is that for getting robust
biomarkers we need even more data sets
that then we have at the moment we also
how did we select biomarker genes so we
wanted them to be separate the positive
to be different both from the negative
and the controls and we say that the
gene is differential if both is cause up
above point 65 and the Q value is
significant and in addition we also
wanted to avoid the situation so for
here is an example for this
hematological cancer we had 14 hundred
samples and but 1100 of them came out of
leukemia so we wanted the Q value to be
significant when we limit our set to the
300 samples that are only a mother to
logical and were not inherited from the
child this is Java to make sure that we
are not inheriting anything from the
Dalai structure so here is one example
of projecting the biomarker on the
protein interaction network this was for
the
broughton cancer and what we see here a
lot of so actually there are two
connected components one is centered
around p53 as expected and the other one
is perhaps more interesting it is buying
far upregulated in mitosis as well as
cell replication and cell cycle however
this network is connected by these two
green nodes that are both annotated as
cytoskeleton which brings up the
hypothesis that impair the wiring of the
replication pathway has a role in cancer
indeed there is some experimental
evidence for this so I'll skip the
disease summary for the time and
summarize this part we created a new
gene expression companion we use
multi-label classification with data set
level cross validation we got good
validation results on RNA sec data
simple approach wins as we end wins over
the multi-level algorithms and there is
an improvement the interpretation is
better using this data say this
compendium by identifying a
disease-specific differential jeans and
I haven't shown you the inter the
summary snapshot that we have
computationally there are two take-home
lessons first of all this issue of
separating the controls and the
background is critical when one analyzes
multi this is data and reproducibility
is still an issue and we need even more
data than this and I'll pass the rest o
DD
so in the second part of the talk we
will extend the flow or at least use
some of the ideas to add the genomic
data naturally for this workshop we will
analyze somatic mutations in cancer
which is great we have the TCGA which
contain you samples but it's not so
great is that we don't have negatives
for it specific subtypes and we already
know that having a control set of
negatives for a subtype is crucial to
learn disease specific signal so we can
use the cosmic database which is a very
large compendium of annotated somatic
mutations right it is easy to work with
there are more than a million samples in
this database but what was you can keep
in mind that the vast majority are
either from small-scale experiments or
we're not annotated or curated yet by
the database on the other hand mapping
the samples to their disease ontology
terms each it's much easier than the
gene expression omnibus many because
cosmic maintain its own controlled
vocabulary whereas where you work with
geo you need to analyze free text which
is a very tough problem and you can
easily met most of these samples to
their disease ontology terms now which
part of this database can we actually
work with for our goals so naturally you
can only use samples that have disease
ontology terms right we cannot run the
flow a lot of samples we will work with
binary associations for when talking
about gene patient pairs so we talk only
gene patient pairs in the database that
are flagged as confirmed somatic
mutations these are considered the high
quality pairs of associations in the
database and last for these slides will
show results from samples for whole
exome studies so we have more than 9,000
patients of which roughly half are from
the TCGA so by going to cosmic we can
get the TCGA data and we have roughly
the same
sample size from additional more or less
100 studies some of which could be very
small so i think the expression case you
want to know for which disease ontology
terms can we learn something that is
robust here we have 50 to terms with at
least 50 patients from at least three
different studies and you can run a
bunch of multi-level algorithms perform
live data set out cross validation and
look at the results that you get we
observed that tree based or random
forest based algorithms work better we
also observed that most terms are tiny
pay 100 samples or two or 200 samples
and you need many trees to gain
robustness and it takes a lot of time to
do that for each disease so basically
what we do is we slightly change the
random forest a burrito without going
into details too much we basically just
down sample the background set of the
disease at the time and now we can
easily learn a thousand or two thousand
trees for each disease as a secondary
effect what you get is is when the
classifier is learned now the negative
sets have more weight when we learn the
algorithm and the classifier these are
some results that we get you can see
here comparison of the different
algorithms just for simplicity by the
number of disease ontology terms with at
least rock score of point 7 for each
algorithm we cut we just count the
number of terms that separates well the
positives from the negatives the
positive from the nikon controls and
their terms that actually perform well
in both here we can see the variant of
the random forest it performs much
better than all other algorithms and
here we can see some specification of
the actual terms that are in this both
measure you and we cover very different
branches of the disease ontology
structure could be benign kidney cancer
and so on and just to give you some
ideas of what is happening here if you
consider colorectal cancer it is really
well separated from the background
however in the sub structure of
intensity
cancers it is not well separated from
others intestinal cancers so it will
have very high separation from the
weapon so it will be counted here but it
is not counted in the both section as
another comment you gain nothing just by
counting the number of mutations in a
sample hey which could be
counterintuitive if you read some of the
recent papers and the main reason here
is is that there are very large
differences between TCGA studies and
there are the cosmic studies just to
show you some example here we just count
the number of mutations per sample in
specific door terms and this is a log to
scale of the number of limitations you
can see that we can have a difference of
by an order of magnitude by the median
number of mutations in a sample this is
here we have more mutations in the TCGA
on this dull term it's completely
reverse in fact 442 disease ontology
terms that we tested in 22 we had a
significant difference between these two
distributions now here it's significant
in 0011 for incorrect that so it's quite
significant in slightly in most cases
with TCGA had more a mutation but it's
not greatest 900 verses 13 this is
another very simple test that we did
just to count the number of mutations
per gene and so here we see a very nice
correlation between the TCGA and non
TCGA supports of cosmic okay another
test that you can do you can say okay
let's learn classifiers on the TCGA
samples and predict them or measure
their performance or the non TCGA
samples and we can do the reverse test
so here the results that you can get
each point is is is a daughter you have
the rock score for the first test and
the rock score for the second test and
interestingly there is no difference in
performance the two subparts of the
database perform more is the same for
most terms in this test you get
relatively high ropes course but we need
to take this or plot with some caution
because there are no negatives in this
analysis okay so in the last part of the
talk I will briefly explain a very
simple way to just interpret the class
if I there is no real algorithmic
contribution here but these simple
analysis actually can help you refine
some of the recent results that map
genes to specific subtypes of cancer so
what do we do for a well classify
disease we just take the genes random
forest importance course you can just
take the top K here we just chose 50 for
the example we also calculate in ritual
scores of the genes we basically just
want to know if the gene is more mutated
in the tested subtypes or or or less
mutated and then we just plot it on
networks and we already know that
viewing these things in the context of
network it's important but we are not
doing anything fancy here so these are
some results that we get for intestinal
cancers to plug the networks we used in
money aside some genes to improve
connectivity in this network the note
size is proportional to the random
forest importance score and the colors
tell us whether or not this gene is more
mutated in intestinal cancer or less
mutated so if you had a red very red
color than you mean that this gene is
very interested intestinal cancers here
we see that summary of the results for
colorectal cancer in the tumor portal
which is based on the paper by Lawrence
2014 and here the genes are partitioned
to three types highly significantly
mutated genes genes that are significant
imitated and genes that are just near
significant so what we can see here we
basically cover most of the highly
significant limitations for the other
types of gene groups there is a very low
coverage in our analysis the other end
we have some very interesting new
candidates for intestinal cancer genes
that have very high importance course
and they are very much mutated in the
disease these are results for kidney
cancer here again we see that we covered
the highly significantly mutated genes
low coverage in the other groups but for
some jeans like like tp53 the sign is
reversed actually in fact when you
analyze the complete cosmic database it
is less
mutated in kidney cancer as compared to
other cancer types okay also we have a
cluster of genes that are tend to be
less mutated in kidney cancer and so you
can think that maybe a possible
biological explanation is that we have a
cluster of genes that have negative
genetic interactions with the main
pathway of kidney cancer just as the
last example we brought you the results
for the 90 plasm so it's a non TCGA
example and what we see here just by
performing the simple analysis we can
capture most of the or many genes that
are cancer genes by Deb and can analysis
most of them are less mutated in bananas
compared to real cancers but some of
them are surprisingly more mutated in
the benign neoplasm like vhl PBR m1 and
m tour right so to summarize my part for
our goals TCGA was not enough we go went
to cosmic and got the added value we can
learn better and faster classifiers just
by treating the negatives and the
background controls differently we can
classify twenty percent of the terms
that we tested some of them are not
covered by the TCGA when we think about
classifier interpretation we
recapitulate the main cancer genes of
each type and we can offer we can refine
the tumor proto result by removing very
low score genes already new candidate or
even new terms to the pool I didn't show
them but we have some analysis of the
small scale data of the cosmic database
here we have many more samples but they
come from a very well pre-selected set
of genes and only a third of the disease
ontology terms become well classified so
it's better than the large-scale
experiments but on the other end I would
argue that it's probably much less than
the what the experts that compose the
database would think of so that was my
last slide we can take questions
right here time for some questions both
have Scott I wasn't my serve compared to
the past when you first bought the asdfs
heroin desk or expression and the second
thought the random forest through the
barrier augmentation yes I wasn't
knowing whether it is significant and
what whether it does reveal something
about the third hour this significant
difference yes it's very sick the
difference is very significant between
the algorithms and they could be that
random forest is much more robust here
in exploiting jeans with very few
mutations if you force better in binary
data but we didn't look into these
different storage is yet one other
comment about this comparison we were a
bit puzzled by the fact that multi-label
classifiers didn't do better but maybe
it's just a problem with with the data
that we have the disease ontology 3 is
relatively large and we don't have rich
in offering presentation of sufficiently
many nodes in order to be able to
exploit the multi-layer
we didn't used it at this point but
there is some correlation with the
number of mutations in a sample and when
we use that we didn't see any other
value
so the Google genes that are
differentially expressed and the group
of genes that I'm you take it today
overlap a lot threesome overlap this is
a part that one didn't show and our next
goal would be to make exploit this in
more detail this was our regional goal
but over time we saw that each time you
when you analyze each part of the
databases the expression of the mutation
it gets more involved so this would be
our next goal but there is some overlap
that is interesting the other questions
I had a question about the mutation
number of mutations in DC GA
personalities in J so this was in cosmic
data that you were looking it is it just
sort of explained by the fact that it
was a different experimental technique
that was used oxo versus correctly some
of them are not only all exome and then
they curate it for could be but in many
cases it's reversed so you have all
exome as that has an order of magnitude
more mutations than TDCJ so it could
explain some of the differences and if
you want to look in this in detail we
used to go back to the raw data and
cosmic and fish out the whole exome
versus all general studies that they
used yeah this is just tons these
corrections were in time is just
straight from them yeah
anything else one more the cosmic data
is also patient-specific like the CGI
and you have to under gate it was there
a specific way or conclusions that you
got from aggregating from differently so
our pre processing is very simple we
just take what they consider as high
quality mutations so you just take the
pair and we don't really exploit well
the type of mutations just use a binary
matrix so it could be that if you
perform or think of better algorithms
that exploit this information you can
get more terms but for now our
processing is very simple
okay good let's think this we use again